Ramon and Celeste are in the lobby of
financial peace Plaza with the five
kiddos hey guys how are you how are you
better than I deserve welcome welcome
where do you guys live in Loma Linda
California in Los Angeles okay so what
in the world are you doing in Nashville
Tennessee we are here to do our
debt-free scream
you made a trek all the way across the
country with five kids absolutely that
free scream so did you fly I hope yep we
flew good very good all right we got to
start off cuz the guys for those of you
that aren't watching at home on your app
on your iPhone or iPad which you should
be or online the young men are all in
suits and ties they are ready to go here
they're dressed up so well I got the
idea for them to dress up well that was
my idea
okay I thought that would be neat okay
good way to meit's a special occasion
and we wanted them to member it okay
very cool I like going to a wedding
absolutely yeah there you go
we could say a funeral the dead is dead
Salome's funeral Salome's funeral that's
right
alright well give me everyone's name
your daughter's first what's your name
she's not on the mic okay gonna do some
downright Chloe mmm-hmm Joshua mmm-hmm
Kaden mmm-hmm Andrew alright
good-looking guys and gals here we go
fun so how much debt have you guys paid
off eight hundred and two thousand
dollars oh okay yeah there's more to
this story yeah how long did this take
three years in 11 months three years 11
months and making what kind of household
income well I started out 240,000 huh
and we went up to about four hundred and
five thousand during that process
holy moly what do you do for a living
I'm a physician ah I was gonna guess
okay what type of practice family
medicine was my residency training but
then I learned er to increase my income
during the process doubled it on both
yeah okay absolutely
wow that's impressive so the eight
hundred and two thousand I hope that
includes your home well that was selling
or one of our houses okay
yah all right we sold a home and we sold
the van that was about three hundred and
eighty thousand of that okay so you paid
off another four hundred thousand three
years yeah
Wow and that was what was that that was
number one was Aunt Sally me my medical
school is about two hundred thousand and
then we had every single loan I never
met a debt we didn't like basically and
we had IRS debt we had business loans we
had family loans we had car loans we had
credit card I mean everything pretty
much whose idea was this - go crazy
three years 11 months ago
well it was kind of both of ours but
what happened was I had heard your radio
show and I heard it was on Friday I
heard a debt free screams going on I
thought that was some fictional fantasy
unicorn leprechauns and then I heard it
amore and I'm like you know what maybe
people maybe these are real but it's not
for me I'm a doctor I'm different I
don't this doesn't apply to me the rules
don't work for doctors the doctor that's
absurd
yeah there so that's what then my wife I
delivered drew our fifth child at home
and she almost died oh and my life
flashed before my eyes and we just
really ate it together what was
important in our life and we said you
know what I want to spend more time at
home and we want to spend time together
as a family and these material things
are keeping us from doing that so how do
we do that and actually we went crazy
before we even heard about you so that's
not nobody can blame you for us going
crazy yeah I actually wanted to sell our
house and sell everything and move to
try to reduce our overhead and our
living expenses to get out of debt
quicker and then we met one of your LPS
and we met that with him and he set up a
good plan that we liked that we were you
know happy with and it got us motivated
inspired and we believed that we could
actually do it after meeting with your
LP yeah so Celeste a is this guy crazy
or you and on the crazy here sounds like
he's he gets a hold of something and
goes with it doesn't he
like yeah just very fun yeah well that's
the kind of people that get things done
I like very fun very fun so Celeste what
was the biggest sacrifice what was the
hardest thing that you guys have done
during this time well probably we had
two things and the first thing was
deciding to sell our home that we just
bought a year before and it was our
dream home it had everything that we
ever wanted in a home
yeah so for about a week I walked around
her house crying looking at everything
and crying but you know that was a week
and then I got over it and we sold the
house but for the next you know almost
four years he was gone a lot and I had
five kids yeah you do most of the time
by myself and she homes the kids okay
this is amazing cuz it's hard to relate
to both ends of these numbers the amount
of debt eight hundred and two thousand
but it's also for hard for people to
relate to making two hundred fifty or
four hundred thousand dollars a year or
something like that what do you say to
people when they hear those numbers and
they feel like they can't relate to them
well absolutely I I felt like you know
the reason why I thought it wasn't
possible and a lot of my friends and you
know what physicians and if you borrow
the maximum amount of medical school
loan over two hundred thousand dollars
we basically lump it in with a mortgage
and say go that's not possible to ever
pay that off you know I'll never be able
to pay my house off so I just won't go
do those two things I'll do everything
else because that's like regular people
that and then but this is this is
different this is special but you have
to I wanted to tell specifically doctors
residents medical students or if you
know a doctor or somebody that's in debt
show them your your show them the Dave
Ramsey information get them to meet with
Annie LP or go to FPU and it'll shatter
your paradigm and you have a huge
paradigm shift and I didn't think it
would be possible to pay off two hundred
thousand dollars in medical school loans
and you know another couple hundred a
couple hundred thousand dollars on you
know two hundred and forty thousand so
but it's possible once you figure out
you're you're willing to do something
that you both want to sacrifice for it's
and you're and it's worth it then you
know I'd learned new skills I worked as
hard as I could we sold as much things
as we could and we lowered our living
expenses by we sold our house and we
rented it but you you've been doing like
80 hours oh we absolutely exactly
because you pick up a yard actually good
absolutely that's how you did this
income you got it you've been working
like an animal yeah you guys are
impressive thank you well this is very
very fun what a great story I don't know
what's been a while since we had on one
that was this much debt that's pretty
impressive and and this much income too
so it's it's a good ratio hey everybody
if you don't if you don't like the
numbers just take a zero off and it
probably applies to you
all right eight hundred and two thousand
dollars paid on three years eleven
months making 240 then four oh five
count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
three two one Boys Choir that's awesome
guys y'all were fun that was a blast but
welcome to Nashville what a great story
oh my goodness hard to get your head
around that one Wow amazing hey if they
can do it you can do it I'll just tell
you
you